would you say then that
the difference between your approach and
cognitive behavioral therapy
is the focus on the recollection of
memory and the destruction
of the initial fear memory as opposed to
trying to build
barrier memories that would inhibit that
original
fear response yeah indeed the difference
is that instead of
building new memories or trying to
control
the emotional memory and the emotional
responses we try to
to yeah mitigate the uh the root of the
disorder so to weaken the fear memory
itself
procedurally it's also very different
because exposure
treatment yeah the idea is that it
actually
targets more the cognitive processes so
the expectancies
it's a it's a longer process so by re
beating people exposing to the feared q
they gradually
learn that uh what they fear is
is irrational whereas we expose our
participants only very briefly
between two and five minutes to the
feared queue
so we don't target the cognitive system
and what is interesting what we see is
first we see a behavior change
so we shall we reduce the defensive
reflex
or in phobics we uh change the
avoidance behavior and when you say
first you see the
change are you talking about after you
give the beta blocker and then you wait
20 minutes or talking about that or the
next day
we actually we found and we published
that paper in
2018 when you test them 12 hours later
on the same day you still see them same
fear expression but only after a night
of sleep
uh we see the sudden very abrupt
reduction of fear so instead of the
gradual decline of the fear response
it's a delayed so after 24 hours but
very
um abrupt and that
especially when when i treat
uh patients and and it is a successful
treatment it's every time
feels like magic because
yeah normally you see a sort of you are
there when you see a sort of gradual
change in behavior and now first you see
during the exposure
that people are really as intense fear
response are sometimes
crying and and panicking and then
if they come back 24 hours later they
are able to
it's not that they're entirely relaxed
uh but yeah there's such a huge
difference so that
really feels like uh it cannot be true
i'm curious you had mentioned the
relationship between
protein synthesis and fear it is known
that protein synthesis that this is
deeply tied with our genetics the
sort of manuscript for the creation of
all of our proteins
do you think it is for this reason that
one finds that in epigenetics that there
are inherited fears
does that have a connection to your
research
yeah no i i'm what do you mean with
inherited fears because i'm a bit
i mean that was also one of the
questions that the fear of snakes i mean
the fears that we treat is of is are the
irrational fears
so not i mean of course i mean snakes
can be dangerous but there's no reason
to be really
phobic in the sense that you that people
avoid
several places because there could be a
snake whereas there is no snake or
so that is the kind of fear that we
treat
um